Superheroing is a tough business.
One minute you're joking around, punching
bad guys in the face, and the next you're
pushing up fictional daisies.
Fortunately, when you've got superpowers,
there's a more than decent chance you'll be
resurrected and given new life...usually because
you're more valuable to your parent company
alive than dead.
Will any of these super-people come back to
life in 2018 or beyond?
Probably...but for now, let's pay our respects
and mourn their super-passings.
And of course...spoilers ahead.
Logan and Professor X
In a year filled with so many superhero flicks,
it's hard to believe that the R-rated Wolverine
swan song, Logan, actually hit theaters in
2017.
But it did — and it was basically a superhero
slaughterfest.
In addition to the demise of Caliban, the
D-lister mutant who was played by comedian
Stephen Merchant, Logan gave a final send
off to two characters who've been thrilling
comic book fans at the movies for nearly 20
years.
Professor X, played by Sir Patrick Stewart,
met an inglorious end at the hands of an evil
Wolverine clone — but not before he practically
stole the show in the movie that was named
for a totally different character.
"Two days on the road, only one meal, and
hardly any sleep.
She's 11 and I'm f---ing 90."
But it was the loss of Logan himself, played
by fan-favorite Hugh Jackman, that fans will
remember for years to come.
Jackman's held the role of Wolverine since
2000's original X-Men movie, and his portrayal
is rightly lauded for helping make superhero
movies the force of nature that they've become.
Given the chance to take the character out
on his own terms, Jackman helps fans say goodbye
to Logan at the movie's end in a beautiful
moment that stands out as not just one of
the most classic moments in a superhero movie,
but one of 2017's best movie moments period.
Patriot
Jeffrey Mace, who in the comics is better
known by his alter ego, the Patriot, debuted
on ABC's Agents of SHIELD in the fall of 2016.
The character, played by Jason O'Mara, was
revealed to be the new director of the super-spy
agency, and at first his name felt more like
an Easter Egg — a nod to longtime comics
readers that the show's producers were reaching
far into Marvel's back catalogue for new characters
to play in their small corner of the MCU.
As time went on, we learned a whole lot more
about the TV version of Mace: he was supposedly
an Inhuman who used his enhanced strength
and invulnerability for the greater good.
But as it happened, this was all bogus: Mace
had no powers, and instead took the television
equivalent of super-steroids.
Sort of like...Crap-tain America.
"No no no no no!"
When the show came back in 2017 after its
mid-season break, Mace and the rest of the
SHIELD team found themselves in the Framework,
a VR simulation where Hydra ran the world,
and the good guys were in hiding.
There, Mace heroically sacrificed himself
to save his fellow agents from doom.
It was a fitting end for the character who,
in the span of only one season, had quickly
became a favorite of fans of the show.
Black Widow
In the 2016 Marvel Comics event Civil War
II, an Inhuman who can see the future shares
a vision with Marvel's heroes.
In it, Miles Morales stands on the steps of
the US Capitol, his costume soaked in blood,
clutching Captain America's lifeless body.
It's a provocative image, and yet it took
a while to get more information.
Then, all the heroes got pretty busy when
Captain America revealed that he was actually
a Hydra sleeper agent, took over S.H.I.E.L.D.,
and conquered the United States.
Man...talk about a real Crap-tain America.
In the follow-up Marvel Comics event story,
Secret Empire, Miles and Steve Rogers met
face-to-face — but neither of them counted
on Natasha.
While Cap and Spider-Man squared off in Secret
Empire #7, the Black Widow had already been
watching on a nearby roof with a sniper-rifle,
hoping to end Captain America's reign with
a single bullet.
When the fight broke out, Black Widow intervened,
hoping to save Spider-Man.
Unfortunately, Captain America's shield broke
Natasha's neck, and she didn't survive.
Once the story was over and finished, the
Cosmic Cube undid all of evil Cap's shenanigans
— but Black Widow stayed underground.
Her funeral took place in Secret Empire #10.
Of course, since she's played by one of the
biggest movie stars on the planet, the chances
of her staying that way for long are basically
slim-to-none.
The Widow will be back in comics pages soon
— count on it.
The Warriors Three
In Thor: Ragnarok, Thor saves most of the
Asgardians from Hela, goddess of the underworld,
with help from Hulk, Valkyrie, and Loki, to
name a few.
He doesn't rescue everyone, however: the Warriors
Three, Thor's rambunctious sidekicks, fight
on the front lines when Hela attacks.
None of them survive the film.
Their defeats are so quick, in fact, that
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige actually
had to explain that the Warriors Three needed
to get decimated to show how big a threat
Hela was.
It worked...but Thor's corner of the MCU is
poorer for it.
Martin Stein
Any Legends of Tomorrow fan who was paying
attention knew that Dr. Martin Stein, better
known as Firestorm's older half, was on the
way out.
In October, right before Legends returned
for its third season, Deadline announced that
actor Victor Garber, who plays Stein, would
be leaving the show so he could replace David
Hyde Pierce in Broadway's Hello, Dolly! revival.
Soon after the news broke, Legends started
planting the seeds for Garber's departure.
Stein was working on a way to separate himself
from Jefferson Jackson, the young man with
whom he merges to create the superheroic Firestorm.
Too bad Nazis show up to spoil the fun.
In a plotline too complicated to adequately
recap here, Stein is shot and separated from
Firestorm, dying after having saved his friends
in the process.
Hello Dolly...goodbye Doctor Stein.
Yondu Udonta
The first Guardians of the Galaxy movie introduced
the world at large to Peter Quill's abductor,
the craggy, drawling Ravager who taught Star-Lord
everything he knows about conniving and swiping
stuff, who's also a wizard with that deadly,
whistling arrow thingie.
Comic book fans, on the other hand, know he
was a core member of the original Guardians
of the Galaxy team.
Yondu got his start in the first appearance
of the team in Marvel Super-Heroes #18 in
1969.
So his turn to the side of good in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2 — and his heroic sacrifice
to save his adopted son Peter — made the
loss all the more memorable by movie's end.
His Ravager funeral just before the film's
credits stands out as one of the most touching
moments we've seen in the MCU yet.
Perhaps most importantly, he managed to make
Mary Poppins cool again.
"You look like Mary Poppins."
"Is he cool?"
"Hell yeah he's cool."
"I'm Mary Poppins, y'all!"
For Disney, Marvel's corporate parent, that's
called vertical integration and corporate
synergy.
And that's the most heroic act of all.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.